caméra café le volume 4 en vhs et dvd 44
également disponible intégral
elle s'engage dans un coffret de 6 dvd
mesdames messieurs voilà pour noël voilà
alors cette série caméra café l'est
resté sept ans dans les tiroirs avant de
démarrer sur m6
d'abord ça a été refusé il faut bien le
dire pas ma part canal + on m'appelle
simple riz non sans rire
l'âge du poids mena nieulay je mène la
vie dans sage gens pourquoi ils ont
refusé canal des gens comme ça tellement
bien parce qu'ils étaient trop riches et
les pauvres a alors qu elle a refusé
ensuite toutes les chaînes ont refusé
cette idée et les gens vous disais à
faire marche ra jamais parce que quand
les gens rentrent chez eux ils n'ont pas
forcément envie de se replonger dans
l'ambiance d'une on pensait que c'était
exactement d'un travail que c'était la
bonne idée je dansais que quand un genre
du travail celle les amuse et peut-être
de se voir caricaturé e ou linge f ou
leurs collègues et on pensait que
c'était justement la bonne formule pour
venant se marchent très bien vous en
foutez de façon tous les connards qui
nous ont refusé votre émission vous en
prenez content c'est pourquoi ils l'ont
acceptée aujourd'hui c'est un jeu de
dupes on le sait il l'a fait aujourd'hui
ça marche encore mieux tout le monde a
accepté parce qu'il y avait un gars une
fille sur france 2 vous croyez parlement
mais ça s'arrose
quel que vous deux regarde le plus la
télé pense que ce mois alors garde quoi
le problème c'est que je regarde plus
rien ouais t'as qu'à voir comment je la
regarde non mais c'est ça le drame
je suis un zappeur invétéré et je finis
par ne plus rien voir ça quand j'ai été
arrêté jeudi so what qu'est ce que tu as
vu rien c'est par meetic
alors c'est moi qui la regardent le plus
parce que moi je regarde j'essaie de pas
trop zapper d'éloigner la nasa peu de le
plus lucide de ma main comme pour garder
j'aime bien regarder émission regardée
quoi bon je vois beaucoup les films
quand même et je regarde tout le monde
en parle
lequel des deux est le plus people alors
là c'est ni l'un ni l'autre
ah bon par contre je suis allé à des
festivals par exemple la montagne ont
tout ce qui est quelque chose de ludique
on se retrouve quelque chose que vous
êtes des souvenirs la montagne ouais
ouais j'en ai quelques uns
pourquoi fils à ma fille la fille qui te
fait croire que tu l'a mise enceinte à
messam et non oui mais sachez c'était
j'avais 15 ans à la salle s'est vu d'un
premier accord pour ne pas dégoûter
lequel va mourir le premier ça me gêne
d'accord l'udc entend sur la télé j'aime
bien
lequel va être oublié le premier bon
mais non je suis posé tout comme ça se
voit pas qui nous provoque non mais
j'aime bien mais ça c'est un peu con
après quand tu vois les missions mais
qui pose des questions et puis les
autres ils disent rien c'est bien quand
même état que j'ai répondu c'est bon
c'est bon peu tu vas tu as entendu parce
que j'ai pas parlé fort le quai a voulu
venir ici ce soir l'attaché de presse